[Musique]
faut dire ce qui est c'est un boulot de
merde mais de nos jours un boulot comme
le mien j'ai 22 ans je gagne huit mille
balles jean trouvera aucun j'en
trouverai aucun c'est sûr et certain
[Musique]
c'est stressant c'est stressant je veux
dire je vais pas faire ça toute ma vie
ça fait la 10e bécane que j'achète la
10e j'ai été obligé de rouler avec des
béquilles j'ai la bouche ouverte il ya
trois mois je me suis ouvert la bouche
peut dire c'est pas un boulot à faire
toute ma vie j'ai essayé d'arrêter de
bosser pour scier mais bon quand j'ai
regardé à droite à gauche qui est pas
table j'ai vu qu'elle est 3 millions et
kf2 chômeurs je me suis dit pourquoi moi
je vais trouver un taf plus vite que les
autres je garde le mien et je ferme ma
gueule
[Musique]
les matins tu compte est bon en général
je compte ma journée je compte mal à la
baisse pour voir ce que j'ai fait à peu
près est ce que j'ai fait à peu près
depuis le début du mois pour pouvoir
conserver une moyenne quoi il alla donc
tu les as grave par les as ouais je sais
par dis donc ça danse ça fait
s'affaisser ya un coursier qui appelait
ça des dollars la place à des dollars
qu'est ce que tu faisais avant dire
qu'on s'y ben
j'ai arrêté l'école j'avais 15 ans et
demi tous que bon c'était pas mon truc
quoi j'étais tout le temps dans la rue
tout en train de galérer et tout et je
traînais avec des gens m'ont je vais pas
dire que c'est des mauvaises
fréquentations c'est moi qui les fais
mes fréquentations à personne m'a mis le
couteau sous la gorge pour faire des
conneries quoi que ce soit et quand j'ai
vu tous mes copains commencé à partir un
peu dans la cale en prison non ces trucs
là j'ai dit bon où je reste à paris et
je fais comme eux parce que j'avais ni
travail ni d'école ça veut dire à 16 ans
tu es libre de faire ce que tu veux des
conneries comme des choses bien et quand
ta saison les choses bien c'est pas très
bas très bas très motivant quoi darien
qui t'intéresse dans les trucs bien
alors ce que j'ai fait c'est que j'ai
pris un billet d'avion je suis parti à
alger chez mes grands parents je vais
essayer de faire quelque chose là-bas
parce qu'en plus ici ça me prenait la
tête quoi je me suis dit là bas je serai
chez moi on ne dira jamais ouais t'es
pas chez toi te crois pas chez toi des
trucs comme ça quoi je me suis dit
d'abord moi je serai chez moi patron je
me suis planté complètement j'étais
encore moins chez moi qui si pendant je
suis resté chez pinsent 16 mois pendant
16 mois on m'appelle émigrés
[Musique]
merci
bonjour
je vais vous prendre le 17e
[Musique]
excusez moi je vous prends ça je dois en
prendre à moi aussi
bonjour
merci bien aux gens
pourquoi il faut livrer plus vite
fou
pour être plus compétent parce que les
clients c'est ce qu'ils demandent
je demande ça tu crois
parce qu'ils ont besoin
c'est fait
alors service hongrois
on peut pas non plus dire non peut pas
refaire ça machin où il ya des fois on
refuse parce qu'il ya des clients qui
sont barge
l'impression qu'on a une fumée dans le
cloud
[Musique]
c'est facile de louer un appartement
dans ton est coursier non non non non on
entend jamais vu mais c'est pas des
bonnes fiches de paye du fils de pêcheur
en béton armé comme on disait des fiches
de paye à 12 me la première était 14 mai
déjà la deuxième a été douze mille 13000
et le reste a suivi ça descendait pas en
dessous de 10 et quand je suis parti
valpré terre il m'a dit d'entrée la même
pas vous la perdez mes fiches de paye
donc les made in m'a dit moi j'ai eu un
coursier ici qui est avant il m'a laissé
une devrait-il de mille balles il est
mort dans l'appartement parce que
c'était un toxico à au moins départ
j'étais bloqué quoi quand il m'a annoncé
que je dispute un juge avait pouvoir la
voir la partie et après je me suis
repris puis je suis rentré dedans moi
j'ai vu peut il parler franc joué par
les franges vous écouter vous n'avez pas
regardé mes fiches de paye moi je vais
vous dire un truc vous regardez mes
fiches de paye quand vous allez voir le
montant de la fiche de paie vous allez
comprendre que je suis pas tu peux pas
me permettre de le chouchouter je te
parle parce que toute la journée faut
que je tienne le coup il faut que je
venais pas encore plus il faut encore
plus de portes à me qui chute qui peut
pas faire ce que je fais c'est
impossible tiendra pas il sera fondé m'a
piqué dizaine sur la bécane à
l'accident c'est logique je lui dis en
plus je vais regarder pour faire des
fiches de paye de ce montant là on peut
pas se permet de montrer une journée on
peut pas se permettre de vendre de la
brague suis bon c'était ça oui mais pas
nombre de drogue ceci aussi est ce lui
c'était noir complètement à la fin j'ai
pas réussi à le convaincre complètement
quoi mais il a vu que j'étais j'étais
bon j'ai des jeunes parce que j'avais
quoi j'avais 21 ans qu'on n'a pas je
veux juste avoir mais parle d'avantagé
plus un appartement et la nuque bon ça
faisait longtemps que je pensais que
j'en voulais il m'a dit
il m'a dit bon ben on va essayer je vais
rencontrer les fiches de paye
on m'a dit ça sert à rien il a dix
fiches de payes tu peux m'en avait des
fossés m'a dit moi ce qui ce que je veux
c'est quand je te regarde dans les yeux
c'est yahia le ca passe moi le courant
passe mais dès que toi ne pourra être
passé maintenant je te fais confiance
c'est ta parole c'est tout et en plus il
m'a donné un parking gratuit gratuit
j'ai rien payer même la clé pour ouvrir
par il m'a donné gratuitement quand al
mahdi web avec va mal pour l'appeler est
à dire non quand on fait un cadeau c'est
totalement rien du tout ici on offre le
parc où elle appelait avec ses plaies et
je vais dire un truc pour loyer il passe
à mon ventre ça m'est déjà arrivé de ne
pas acheter de 2,2 de ne pas aller faire
les courses pour pouvoir payer le loyer
arrivé plusieurs fois et ça me gêne pas
de leur faire c'est pas un problème mais
quand tu as pu le travail était
locataire ça va vite la chute elle est
aussi rapide que la montée ça va très
très très vite tu perds ton taf n'a plus
de quoi payer son loyer au bout
d'eux-mêmes pas de moi thé à la rue thé
à la rue et ça c'est un truc qui me fait
hyper flipper on retrouve à la rue parce
que bon
décembre c'est hyper rapide mais
remonter
[Musique]
gadio
défense doit aller chercher des
dépliants à l'aéroport même un taxi
pourra pas le faire parce que quand il
va revenir il va y avoir deux heures
d'embouteillage et la cassette elle doit
passer à 13 heures au journal ou une
connerie pareille celui moto pourra
passer c'est le seul truc
mais ce qu'il ya c'est que les gens sont
pas reconnaissants ils reconnaissent pas
ça
on a un bout de viande sur un scooter
[Musique]
tu les veux
grosse poubelle de merde on n'est pas
respectée mais alors pas du tout
d'ailleurs souvent quand je passe sur
les extérieurs quand je vois
les prostituées plusieurs fois j'ai vu
des coursiers discuter avec les
prostituées bon je me suis dit c'est
clair et net il va pas l'emmener sur son
scooter faire un tour quoi et je me suis
dit qu'est ce qui peut bien lui raconter
en fin de compte en bon en roulant
réfléchit beaucoup on est comme je suis
tout seul toute la journée j'arrête pas
de réfléchir et de penser à tout et à
rien et des fois je me disais en fin de
compte les députés sont comme nous quoi
elles sont sur le trottoir
sont toute la journée en train
d'attendre des clients comme nous on a
toute la journée dans paris avec le bip
et on attend que ça sonne pour qu'ils
aient une course est plus à fond de
clients plus affront de d'oseille tard a
peut-être un fils ouais moi j'arrive à
avoir ce pas 16 17 18 il à dire nabil
j'ai envie de faire conseiller je veux
faire conseiller tu à lui dire
j'vais pas je pourrai pas je pourrais
pas le laisser franchement je peux pas
c'est trop galère je sais ce que c'est
tu le poussera à faire des études
poussé dans tous et non pas ce que je
fais pas je vais pas non plus stressés
mon gosse a à lui faire faire tout ce
que j'ai pas pu faire c'est qu'on sait
qu'on je suis pas con à ce point non je
le laisserais faire ce qu'il veut mais
j'essaierai de pousser quand même un
petit peu sur les études un minimum
points
d'instruction parce que j'ai quitté les
études tôt mais ça va quand même
j'arrive à me démerder
mais bien parce que je dis beaucoup je
suis pas autodidacte mais bon il faut
dire que je fais beaucoup moins de
fautes depuis que je lis beaucoup
disaient qu'ils ne la citc représente
pas pour toi
pour moi la cité c'est la rue c'est
l'école c'est je suis bien content d'y
être passé franchement parce que
dans mes connaissances j'ai eu plein de
mecs qui ont vécu pas disons qu'ils sont
pas nés là là la cuillère en or dans la
bouche mais presque quoi et maintenant
c'est des moins que rien c'est des mecs
qui ont pu à la naissance et quand le
jour il a ils ont fallu qu'ils se
démerdent de même ils ont jamais réussi
moi je connais un mec ses parents
s'étaient des bourges lui c'était un
bourge à 18 ans elle avait déjà sa
voiture il avait son permis il avait
tout ce mec là tous les ans ils étaient
sur la côte en vacances alors que l'on
parte en bretagne avec la mairie pour ça
s'emballe et les bons vacances d'accord
mais maintenant il a fait des études et
où il travaille chez flunch tu vois pas
et gagne 5000 francs je veux dire c'est
pas je dis pas que le mec qui bosse chez
flunch il gagne six mille balles cc
c'est une merde non d'accord c'est un
boulot moi tous les boulots même
balayeur je m'en fous je le ferai si je
dois nourrir mes gosses n'importe quoi
pour payer mon loyer nourrir mes gosses
et et subvenir à ma famille je ferais
n'importe quoi tout sauf ramener de
l'argent volé ou de la drogue ou ces
trucs là l'argent talent à l'âme comme
on dit chez nous l'argent du péché faut
pas nourrir les gosses faut pas manger
avec faux pas je veux dire jamais j'ai
racheté une pièce ou volés pour ma
bécane
c'est un truc tu porteras la poisse je
le sais j'aimerais pas avoir une sacoche
qui a été volé un autre corps siégerait
pas tranquille ça va me porter la poisse
je peux avoir un accident à cause d'une
connerie pareille et là c'est la même
chose par contre faire n'importe quel
métier je le ferai c'est ça que je dis
que le mec qui travaille chez flunch
c'est un boulot mais le mec qui a fait
des études six ans après le bac qui se
retrouve chez flunch c'est un moins que
rien pour moi c'est un moins que rien
qu'est-ce qu'il a été galéré six ans
d'études il aurait pris but il aurait
arrêté les études six ans avant il
aurait déjà un appart une voiture et
machin il serait marié leur et des
gosses lait se retrouvent à 30 piges il
a fait comme un malade il a une licence
de chez pas quoi qui lui sert à rien et
il se retrouve chez flunch moi ça ça
quand je vois ça je me dis [ __ ] mais
où est ce qu'on va où est ce qu'on va si
les mecs qui n'ont pas de diplôme ils
s'en sortent mieux que les mecs qui ont
des diplômes je comprends les mecs
qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent écoles
site allait porter un pli
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
et tu le rencontres
qu'est ce tu lui dis bonjour j'ai un pli
pour vous dis merci au revoir c'est tout
ça s'arrête là je le calcul même pas il
ya eu 1 une fois on a eu un coursier de
chez nous qui a livré chez le pen
alors si ça plaît à kim les cheveux bien
frisé la barbe bien bronzé en étaient
morts de rire ayrton senna c'est vrai
que c'est quelqu'un de connu c'est vrai
que c'est quelqu'un qui sait tuer mais
tous les jours il ya des mecs question
on n'en parle pas tous les jours sur le
périph yann hakiki des sabots
un coursier un costard cravate comme je
les appelle c'est les touristes quoi les
mecs qui ont des bécanes qui vont de
chez eux au boulot du boulot aux h&e un
costard cravate un coursier qui que ce
soit quelqu'un qui meurt c'est ça fait
ça fait ça fait un peu mal le sida c'est
chou sida c'est dangereux le sida faut
faire gaffe le sida faut prévenir tout
le monde faut prévenir sur tous les
gosses c'est sacré les gosses faut
qu'ils soient prévenus des plus jeune
âge parce que c'est sûr qu'à quelques
mois même moi je serais gêné d'aller
dire à mon gosse qui a dix piges ou
quinze piges fais gaffe si tu attires un
coût mais une capote jeu c'est sûr je
serais gêné mais je préfère être gêné
est même passé un peu points pas un
conte disons mais un lourd comme on dit
que un jour mon gosse 30 et me disent
ouais j'ai le sida ça serait con
la can c'est dégueulasse la came c'est
la mort la came c'est
ça descriptif moi je vois des mecs qui
crèvent tous les joueurs de la cam
j'arrête pas je vois des coursiers qui
piquent du nez on fait rouge je vois des
coursiers les mecs qui il est sur son
vespa il fait le drapeau tellement il
pèse plus rien tellement jagdeo
tellement il est blanc je me demande
comment il fait encore pour pouvoir
tourner c'est dément la cam la came
c'est la mort c'est la mort en direct
c'est la mort à petit feu pour moi la
religion en vérité chacun devrait se la
faire soi même une bonne religion c'est
quand on respecte tout le monde mais on
respecte les gens ont les vols pas on
tue pas on en passe et ça pour moi une
bonne religion maintenant que le mec
qu'ils soient juifs qu'ils soient arabes
qui enfin musulmans où qu'ils soient
chrétiens tant qu'ils emmerdent pas le
monde et que
moi c'est un mec bien il ya une musique
que j'aime bien c'est celle que c'est
dit tout à l'heure c'est war de bob
marley parce que c'est bon je comprends
pas l'anglais pas monsieur tirs entendus
un peu la traduction il dit tant que les
gens n'accepteront pas les différences
entre entre eux il y aura toujours des
problèmes il y aura toujours des guerres
partout
ça veut tout dire
[Musique]